merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la rapporteur mes chers
collègues
chers collègues c'est avec pas mal
d'émotions que je viens ici présenter ma
proposition de loi pour la création d'un
registre national des cancers
avant tout je tiens à remercier mon
groupe et nous recentrisme d'avoir
permis sa discussion et tous les
collègues sur tous les bons du Sénat qui
ont soutenu largement cette proposition
de loi je remercie aussi bien sûr madame
la rapporteur ma collègue Nadia sologo
pour son travail précis argumenté ainsi
que la commission des affaires sociales
dont les apports ont modifié utilement
le contenu de ce texte
avec émotion donc car cette proposition
de loi est l'aboutissement de plusieurs
années d'engagement et d'échanges pour
confirmer l'utilité d'un tel registre
en effet cet outil est considéré comme
indispensable par un très grand nombre
d'acteurs et ceux dont le but
d'améliorer et de rendre plus efficace
la lutte contre le cancer dans toutes
ses dimensions
mes chers collègues ma conviction de la
vertu scientifique d'un registre a
député débuté à l'occasion de mon
travail de thèse soutenu en 1998 je
reconnais c'est pas tout jeune et qui
portait sur l'exposition professionnelle
à l'amiante et le risque de cancer
digestif
sans la qualité à l'époque du registre
des cancers digestifs du cavados et
l'accès simple à ses données ce travail
n'aurait pas abouti nous avions alors
mis en évidence une surincidence de
cancer digestif dans une population
professionnellement exposée et fait
important une relation d'os effet entre
la quantification de l'exposition à
l'amiante et l'apparition d'un cancer
digestif
ceci à l'illustration d'un fait on le
sait l'épidémiologie ne s'approche au
plus près de la vérité scientifique que
si elle s'adosse à une observation
rigoureuse et réelle de la pathologie en
l'occurrence dans le texte qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui c'est bien un
registre national général des cancers
qu'il s'agit
j'ai donc logiquement depuis ces années
de recherche conçu la conviction qu'il
nous fallait en France se doter d'un tel
outil depuis cette conviction m'a
toujours suivie et c'est renforcée et ce
pour plusieurs raisons
tout d'abord que ce soit les constants
progrès diagnostics la nécessité
d'améliorer sans cesse dépistage et la
prévention les besoins d'identifier les
nouveaux facteurs de risque émergents
dans un environnement changeant où les
expositions à des facteurs exogènes sont
nombreux liés à l'évolution rapide de
notre mode de vie et bien sûr la
révolution thérapeutique qui avance si
rapidement tous ces sujets sont autant
de défis qui méritent que nous nous
saisissions de ce registre national
car l'accès rapide à une donnée fiable
éprouvée et rigoureuse est essentielle
pour apporter suivi et la bonne réponse
mais aussi c'est de la société elle-même
qui est venue un mouvement à la fois de
soutien et de souhaits que ce registre
soit constitué chercheur médecins et
professeurs sociétés savantes
associations de Pierre passion comme
France à 60 la Ligue nationale contre le
cancer encore tout récemment qui vient
de me confirmer son soutien les réseaux
des registres de cancers Francim la
volonté est là que ce texte aboutisse
j'en profite ici pour vous témoigner
parmi ces soutiens de celui du
professeur Guillot efficace et constant
auteur d'un rapport adopté en décembre
2021 par l'Académie de médecine et qui
approuve et qui accompagne de façon
nette la nécessité d'un registre
national des cancers
j'ai grâce à lui pu assister à de
nombreuses auditions ayant constitué la
base de ce rapport et qui ont bien sûr
alimenté ce travail législatif tout
récent c'est donc logiquement à l'issue
d'un cheminement long et motivant que
cette proposition de loi arrive
aujourd'hui en examen au Sénat c'est
ajouter à ces arguments une motivation
supplémentaire parce que la révolution
numérique permet aux données de santé de
connaître un développement certain et
que la promesse de l'intelligence
artificielle laisse envisager des
perspectives nouvelles nul ne peut
ignorer à la fois la nécessité d'un
contrôle public ferme et exclusif du
recueil et de l'usage de ces données qui
sont intimes et pourtant alimentent de
nombreux appétits allant de la
manipulation des données parfois
excessives non encadrées très
scientifique aux usages y compris à des
fins mercantiles ou commerciales ne
soyons pas naïfs sur ces sujets la
start-up nation avance mais l'expertise
et le contrôle humain dans un but de
santé publique on devient encore plus
indispensables
un registre des concerts national aux
données vérifiées encadrées photographie
réelle actuelle des cancers et de leur
évolution dans le temps hébergé par
l'incadre la fonction éminemment
d'utilité publique serait ainsi la
garantie pour tous que ces données
propriétés de chacun resterait protégé
protégeant ton retour les citoyens voici
madame la Présidente Monsieur le madame
la ministre mes chers collègues ce que
je souhaitais vous apporter en préambule
de ces discussions et vous dire ainsi ma
conviction intime intense de la
nécessité de la création d'un registre
national des cancers le temps est venu
de mettre fin de mettre enfin un cadre à
de nombreuses années de tergiversations
pas toujours justifiée ni justifiables
et de prendre la décision qui s'impose
de créer ce registre les outils et les
compétences sont là vous pouvez
constater sur ma détermination à faire
avancer ce sujet à son terme forte à la
fois de nombreux soutiens trouvés ici au
Sénat et de ce si nombreux de la société
civile je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci